à la mairie d'Amiens il va y avoir des
tas de secteurs qui vont être en grève
qui le sont pas d'habitude que dans des
communes rurales il y aura pas le
service minimum qui sera fait que dans
les écoles elles sont fermées donc on
verra bien demain qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce jeudi 19 janvier pour moi c'est
l'heure des comptes il y aura aussi
beaucoup de grève dans les entreprises
privées dans la commerce la distribution
l'agroalimentaire la métallurgie donc
vous êtes sûr de ça on ne voit pas de
mes vision forte dans les entreprises
privées à ce stade mais encore une fois
je suis très prudent parce que
l'expérience montre que personne n'est
vraiment capable de prédire comment
évolue un mouvement social dans d'autres
pays vous avez une estimation je reviens
à ma question du taux de grévise dans le
privé ou pas déjà c'est impossible vous
savez combien il y a d'entreprises et
malheureusement on n'est pas implanté
dans toutes les entreprises mais il y a
dans certains grands groupes des taux de
grévistes qui vont avoisiner les 60 70 %
je dis là 19 janvier prochain que les
murs de l'Elysée doivent trembler ces
jeudis prochain qu'Elizabeth borne doit
ravaler sa réforme des retraits nous
préparons sur le fait qu'il y ait du
monde et il y a plus de 10000 policiers
gendarmes qui seront mobilisés demain
dont 3500 à Paris nous espérons que
cette expression populaire ne se
transformera pas en blocage être capable
de contester de manifester de débattre
oui bloquer le pays et bloquer le
quotidien des Français non un petit
millier de personnes à Paris qui
pourrait être violent alors soit c'était
ultra jaune comme on dit ou des ultra
gauche la nupesse la gauche joue là
aussi sa force d'opposition mais elle
promet pour l'instant une belle
convergence des luttes c'est ce qui a
souligné marine tondeuillier hier soir
la nouvelle patronne des Verts non
seulement nous allons manifester le 19
janvier tous les jours qui suivront mais
surtout puisqu'on nous demande qu'est-ce
qu'on propose on va vous proposer
quelque chose nous revendiquons que nous
ne voulons plus en France 2
milliardaires nous nous voulons une
France 100 milliardaires
vous avez vu que ça me révèle que les
milliardaires sont encore plus
milliardaires ça vous dit qu'il faut
couper là-bas ça serait bien que qu'on
coupe qu'on leur coupe l'électricité
pour qu'ils se puisse se mettre dans la
peau
quelques jours de des millions de foyers
français qui sont en précarité
énergétique on ne peut pas avoir une
poignée de personnes qui génère une
pagaille pour des millions de Français
et bien pour une fois je suis d'accord
avec Madame berger et donc on ne peut
pas avoir une poignée de millionnaire au
gouvernement qui décide tout seul de
pourrir la vie des gens ne perturbons
pas un système qui est un système qui
fonctionne bien qui repousse sur la
solidarité entre ceux qui travaillent et
ceux qui travaillent
et comme toujours Oxfam confond tout
avec la Nupe ce nous n'en sommes plus là
on rêve du grand soir d'un 1789 de la
finance d'une révolution rouge et verte
pour construire quoi un monde sans
argent sans différence sans liberté
piloter par un petit groupe d'apparatchs
qui instaurerait une nouvelle noblesse
le 20e siècle a fourni quelques exemples
de ce genre tout comme Napoléon a
mobilisé presque toute l'Europe contre
l'Empire russe tout comme Hitler a
mobilisé la plupart des pays européens
pour les lancer contre l'Union
soviétique aujourd'hui les États-Unis
ont monté une coalition avec presque
tous les pays européens membre de l'OTAN
et de l'Union européenne un coup monté
une fausse arrestation juste pour les
caméras beaucoup de commentaires de ce
genre à propos de l'interpellation de
Greta Thunberg hier en Allemagne lors
d'une manifestation contre l'extension
d'une mine de charbon à ciel ouvert cela
le patron
me fait un peu peur mais mais pourquoi
elle nous fait peur pourquoi
une pendule parce que l'heure est grave
vous lui chantiez déjà c'est la nouvelle
génération ils sont ils sont bon très
bien il faut dire que les précautions
prises par les policiers qu'il apporte
peuvent surprendre tout comme l'air
décontracté de la jeune militante et son
rire quand tout se pose devant les
caméras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle était elle la doyenne de l'humanité
on a appris la disparition de se rendre
qui est décédé à l'âge de 118 ans elle
s'était éteint pendant son sommeil à
Toulon
[Applaudissements]